with the decline of symmetric encryption
algorithms for private message
encryption new cypher suits have come
into the light
the glaring issue with symmetric
algorithm was key exchange
having to pass secret keys is a risk in
its own right
now that we are unable to solve in all
the scenarios
thankfully the dsa algorithm has managed
to solve this problem
the use case for the cipher is rather
niche but crucial nonetheless while the
ds algorithm is exclusively used for
verification and transmission of
signatures the rsa algorithm can be used
for general data encryption and
decryption as well
functioning on a similar public key
cryptography architecture it is seen as
a more complex solution to bolster
security
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we first get a recap on what asymmetric
encryption is and how is it any
different from symmetric encryption
we learned what digital signatures are
and how they are used in today's world
next we understand the digital signature
algorithm and see how it works step by
step
moving on we learn about the advantages
dsa provides when it comes to managing
digital signatures in a corporate
environment
next we understand the rsa algorithm and
see how it works from a layman's
perspective
we understand how rsa can be used to
encrypt and decrypt general data apart
from digital signatures and finally we
learn about the advantages rsa provides
when it comes to managing digital
signatures and encrypted information
let's take a look at asymmetric
encryption
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
the public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and the private
key is used to decrypt the data
post-transit
this pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared by a
messaging blog post or key servers since
there are no restrictions
as you can see in the image the two keys
working in the system
the sender first encrypts the message
using the receiver's private key after
which we receive the ciphertext
the ciphertest is then transmitted to
the receiver without any other key
on getting the ciphertext the receiver
can use his or own private key to
decrypt the information and get the
clear text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt messages and the
private key which can decrypt messages
need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
for as often as long as possible
in this example we have two people nancy
and john
if nancy wants to send a message to john
john's public key should be used to
encrypt the information
the cipher text is then transferred to
john who can use his private key to
decrypt the data and get the plain text
back
this goes to highlight how we have
overcome the problem of key sharing when
it comes to asymmetric encryption
now that we have a proper revision let's
understand what digital signatures are
before moving on to the algorithm
the objective of digital signatures is
to authenticate and verify documents and
data
this is necessary to avoid tampering and
digital modification or forgery of any
kind during the transmission of official
documents
they work on the public key cryptography
architecture with one exception
typically an asymmetric key system
encrypts using a public key and decrypts
the private key
for digital signatures however the
reverse is true
the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key
because the keys are inked together
decoding it with the public key verifies
that the proper private key was used to
sign the document therefore verifying
the signature's provenance
let's go through each step to understand
the procedure thoroughly
in step 1 we have m which is the
original plain text message
and it is passed on to a hash function
denoted by h
to create a digest
next it bundles the message together
with the hash digest and encrypts it
using the sender's private key
it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender's public key
once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function
each hash to generate a similar digest
it compares the newly generated hash
with the bundled hash value received
along with the message if they match it
verifies data integrity
in many instances they provide a layer
of validation and security messages
through non-secure channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender
digital signatures are equivalent to
traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type
digital signature schemes in the sense
used here are cryptographically based
and must be implemented properly to be
effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret
further some non-repudiation schemes
offer a timestamp for the digital
signature so that even if the private
key is exposed the signature is valid
to implement the concept of digital
signature in real world we have two
primary algorithms to follow
the rsa algorithm
and the ds algorithm but the latter is a
topic of learning today
so let's go ahead and see what the
digital signature algorithm is supposed
to do
digital signature algorithm is fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures
it was proposed in 1991 and globally
standardized in 1994 by the national
institute of standards and technology
also known as the nist
it functions on the framework of modular
exponential and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute system
unlike dsa most signature types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data
since just the message digest is sign
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was saying
as a result digital signatures impose
less load on processors at the time of
signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth
dsa on the other hand does not encrypt
message digest using private key or dkip
message digest using public key
instead it uses mathematical functions
to create a digital signature consisting
of two 160 bit numbers which are
originated from the message digest and
the private key
dc's make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with rsa
dsa also provides three benefits
which is the message authentication
integrity verification and
non-repardiation
in the image we can see the entire
process of dsf validation a plain text
message is passed on to a hash function
where the digest is generated which is
passed on to a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g
of random variable k
and the private key of the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with the plain text and
sent to the receiver
the two outputs we receive from the
signing functions are the two 160 bit
numbers denoted by s and r
the receiver end we pass the plain text
to the same hash function to regenerate
the message digest
it is passed on to verification function
which has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender global variable
g and snr received from the sender
the value generated by the function is
then compared to r
if they match then the verification
process is complete and data integrity
is verified
this was an overview of the way the dsa
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next section
we have three phases here the first of
which is key generation
to generate the keys we need some
prerequisites
we'd select a queue which becomes a
prime divisor
we select a prime number p such that p
minus one mod q equal to zero
we also select a random integer g which
must satisfy the two formulas being
mentioned on the screen right now
once these values are selected we can go
ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by x and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of 0 and the value
of q
the public key can be calculated as y
equal to g to the power x mod p
where y stands for the public key
the private key can then be packaged as
a bundle which comprises of values of p
q g and x
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p
q
g and y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this generation
repeat
once the keys are generated we can start
generating the signature
the message is passed through a hash
function to generate the digest h first
we can choose any random integer k which
falls under the bracket of 0 and q
to calculate the first 160 bit number of
our signing function of r we use the
formula g to the power k mod p into mod
cube
similarly to calculate the value of the
second output that is s we use the
following formula that is shown on the
screen
the signature can then be packaged as a
bundle having r and s
this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver
now with the third phase we have to
verify the signature
we first calculate the message i just
received in the bundle by passing it to
the same hash function
we calculate the value of w u1
and u2 using the formulas shown on the
screen
we have to calculate a verification
component which is then to be compared
with the value of r being sent by the
sender this verification component can
be calculated using the following
formula
once calculated this can be compared
with the value of r if the values match
then the signature verification is
successful and the entire process is
complete starting from key generation to
the signature generation all the way up
to the verification of the signature
with so many steps to follow we are
bound to have a few advantages to boot
this and we would be right to think so
dsa is highly robust in the security and
stability aspect when compared to
alternative signature verification
algorithms
we have a few other ciphers that aim to
achieve the simplicity and the
flexibility of dsa but it has been a
tough ask for all the other suits
the key generation is much faster when
compared to the rsa algorithm and such
while the actual encryption and
decryption process may falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of frameworks
dsa requires less storage space to work
its entire cycle
in contrast its direct correspondent
that is rsa algorithm needs a certain
amount of computational and storage
space to function efficiently this is
not the case with dsl which has been
optimized to work with weaker hardware
and lesser resources
the dsa is patented but nist has made
this pattern available worldwide royalty
free
a draft version of the speculation
fips1865
indicates that dsa will no longer be
approved for digital signature
generation but it may be used to verify
signatures generated prior to the
implementation date of that standard
the rsa algorithm is a public key
signature algorithm developed by ron
rivest adi shamir and leonard edelman
the paper was first published in 1977
and the algorithm uses logarithmic
functions to keep the working complex
enough to withstand brute force and
streamlined enough to be fast post
deployment
rsa can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification
let us understand how it achieved this
we take our plain text message m we pass
it through a hash function to generate
the digest h which is then encrypted
using the sender's private key
this is appended to the original plain
text message and sent over to the
receiver
once the receiver receives the bundle we
can pass the plain text message to the
same hash function to generate a digest
and the ciphertext can be decrypted
using the public key of the sender the
remaining hashes are compared if the
values match then the data integrity is
verified and the sender is authenticated
apart from digital signatures the main
case of rsa is encryption and decryption
of private information before being
transmitted across communication
challenge
this is where the data encryption comes
into play when using rsa for encryption
and decryption of general data it
reverses the key set usage
unlike signature verification it
receives the receiver's public key to
encrypt the data and uses the receiver's
private key in decrypting the data
thus there is no need to exchange any
keys in this scenario there are two
broad components when it comes to rsa
cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data
the second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the ciphertext
you will now understand each of these
steps in a next sub-topic
keeping the previous two concepts in
mind let us go ahead and see how the
entire process works starting from
creating the keeper to encrypting and
decrypting the information
you need to generate the public and
private keys before running the
functions to generate cipher text and
plain text they use certain variables
and parameters all of which are
explained
we first used two large prime numbers
which can be denoted by p and q
we can compute the value of n as n equal
to p into q and compute the value of z
as p minus 1 into q minus 1.
a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number d is also selected at random
following the formula e d mod j equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given below
the public key is then packaged as a
bundle with n and e and the private key
is packaged as a bundle using n and d
this sums up the key generation process
for the encryption and decryption
function we use the formula c
and m
the ciphertext can be calculated as c
equal to m to the power e mod n and the
plaintext can be calculated from the
cipher text as c power d mod n
when it comes to a data encryption
example
let's take p and q as 7 and 13.
the value of n can be calculated as 91.
if we select the value of e to be 5 it
satisfy all the criteria that we needed
to
the value of d can be calculated using
the following function which gives it as
29 the public key can then be packaged
as 91 comma 5 and the private key can
then be packaged as 91 comma 29.
the plain text if it is 10 which is gray
noted by m
ciphertext can be calculated to the
formula c equal to m to the power e mod
n which gives us 82.
if somebody receives this ciphertext
they can calculate the plain text using
the formula c to the power d mod n which
gives us the value of 10 as selected as
our plain text
we can now look at the factors that make
the rsa algorithm stand out versus its
competitors in the advantageous topics
of this lesson
rsa encryption depends on using the
receiver's public key so that you don't
have to share any secret key to receive
the messages from others
this was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography structure
since the key pairs are related to each
other a receiver cannot intercept the
message since they didn't have the
correct private keys to decrypt the
information
if a public key can decrypt the
information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private anymore
the encryption process is faster than
that of the dsa algorithm
even if the key generation is slower in
rsa many systems across the world tend
to reuse the same keys so that they can
spend less time in key generation and
more time on actual cipher text
management
data will be tamper proof in transit
since meddling with the data will alter
the usage of the keys
the private key won't be able to decrypt
the information hence alerting the
receiver of any kind of manipulation in
between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
transit the cases of which are rather
low
hope you learned something new today if
you have any questions from today's
session be sure to let us know in the
comment section below subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this and
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here